[Music]
hello there reject nation
i'm greg alba i'm john humphrey and i'm
stacy howard
look at us we're professionals what up
what up now that the embargo has been
released and everyone has gotten their
review up we figured we'd wait a while
and let ours go
up later so we don't get lost in the mix
i don't know if that was a bad call in
mind or not
let's see how this video performs we're
gonna talk about captain marvel today
guys
non-spoiler review we will be doing a
spoiler review later on this week you
probably won't be joining us because
you're so busy and all those things
yeah super busy and oh stacy transition
what are you busy with these days
oh my gosh so many things but the thing
i'm most excited about is that i am
helping to plan and organize
molten festa this
is a film festival we are throwing in
hollywood at the egyptian theater
legendary film critic leonard malton
himself along with his family jesse
malton and alice malton
is throwing maltinfest this is a film
festival dedicated to film
fans cinephiles you're going to get
feature films short films documentaries
special events
receptions all kinds of fun stuff with
incredible special guests like
doug benson to play the leonard malton
game that's gonna be epic you got holly
payne
you got joe dante you got some
incredibly talented filmmakers producers
actors the whole slate the whole
lineup's gonna be announced later but
you can get your weekend badges
on sale right now at leonardmalton.com
malton fest you guys tickets are live
it's going to be incredible
louis ck is going to be performing there
morgan freeman's making a guest
appearance
so much you're produced by harvey
favorite people
will be all the best people in hollywood
that are not problematic will be there
it's gonna be a good time well make sure
to go do that today we might stop by
there
let's talk about captain marvel now
shall we now that i have finally seen
this movie i am no longer sexist
and i also hate white men according to
the internet of what breedlock actually
i haven't followed anything
literally but one thing breed larson
hates white men in my mind there's
probably more to this story
than there is there's never more to the
story than the headlines
everything i'm like i have zero opinion
about that i don't know anything about
that
we're gonna keep it non-spoiler what are
your guys's general
thoughts on this movie let's start with
stacy because it's you know female lead
feminist movie
yeah boobies um guys boobies
and there are so many in this is so
amazing no there are actually no boobs
um i had
a really fun time with this i thought it
was a solid
standalone marvel film a great origin
story
to introduce me to a character that i
really knew nothing about i don't read
comic books
so going into these films i judge them
solely on the
cinematic experience alone i don't bring
anything into it in terms of the history
of the character and everything
i had a good time with it i really liked
it what'd you guys think
i wound up having a blast with this too
actually i mean i
appreciated especially seeing the movie
that they held back so much from
the trailers and yeah this was one of
the marvels that kind of pulled me in
immediately and didn't let me go until
the end and
my only gripes are kind of minimal so i
had a great time with this
well here's my opinion
get ready my experience with the film i
enjoyed it a lot i really had a
really good time and really fun time
watching it i wouldn't say i liked it a
lot though for me it's a very
mixed bag there are things i really like
there are things about it that i
actually
love but there's a few things just a few
that i feel pretty strongly about that
are not really steered in a positive
direction for me
women uh only the women in this film you
know
i thought call it captain nick fury
instead
the things that i really did appreciate
about this movie that i think everyone
would be on board for
it goes without saying the visual
effects in this film are absolutely
dynamite the production design here was
great i love the costumes i really
enjoyed the makeup aesthetic as well
and there's a lot of makeup there's a
lot of makeup there's a yeah so much
makeup
but a lot of creatures almost every
movie has makeup
but there are a lot of practical
creatures i know what you're saying yeah
there's some cool world building in here
as well
i really think the supporting cast in
the film is spectacular and
you know you don't often say that about
the standalone films or the whole
supporting ensemble
like nick fury sam jackson was awesome
in the film i loved his
buddy cop dynamic that he had with bree
larson in the movie a lot of people talk
about the cat goose
and i think a lot of what makes goose
really shine in the movie is actually
sam jackson's interaction with you
kissy faces yeah which is what i do
every time i see both of you guys i'm
like oh hey
[Music]
um no i really like that we get to see a
young
energetic nick fury i mean he's not this
you know
old grizzled you know guy that's seen it
all in every kind of alien and race and
saved the world a million times this is
a guy
who until you know the the day the film
starts had no idea about what's going on
but he just kind of accepts it
and rolls with it because he was like i
like i like this like he was he was on
board
from the second he met her was really
the heart of the film in my opinion was
nick fury john
do you like samuel jackson yeah i i
loved him
so john's in that weird position where
we say everything and then he has to
yeah
i agree yeah yeah no he's definitely a
favorite part of the movie for me and i
thought that the buddy dynamic really
shone out and the car chase that he's
involved with was one of my favorite
action sequences of the film and it was
an example of a way in which the movie
starts to feel like a 90s movie without
having to make a 90s joke
and so i thought he did a whole lot for
that and i thought the thing they did on
him whatever they did
yeah looked spectacular because i could
tell it was there on on uh
clark gregg yeah he looked a little bit
like dennis quaid
meshed with his own seat yeah yeah and i
also think uh the the performer that
we all know he's a great actor but
usually in these kind of films there
they don't really get the chance to
shine
i thought he would be the actor who's
underutilized where you're like man they
really should have taken advantage of
having him
but they did more with him and it would
be spoiler territory if we went into it
ben mendelsohn as uh the leader of the
scrolls in this movie
did not expect this performance from
this guy and i can't i really can't go
into details because it would totally
ruin the movie for you it's a great
performance
he's not just the same character you've
seen him play in like ready player one
and star wars he's not a cliche villain
yeah he's he's not that same character
he's been playing for
a few movies he's like the go-to of that
guy
yeah corporate
called ben mendelsohn lashana lynch as
maria rambo she comes in late into the
film
she's so good like her first scene that
has a good amount of dial on our very
first scene but there's one scene where
she has a pretty good amount of dialogue
pretty when uh
late into the movie it got me
emotionally hooked like she is
really really good in this movie i do
think the supporting cast was really
cool i thought there was some really
good action in here as well
other than a few moments that had some
hand-to-hand combat where i
had a hard time telling what was going
on because there's a lot of editing with
the hand-to-hand combat
i still think there were some pretty
stellar action sequences
my biggest issue with the movie and i
found
that after i got out of the film i
talked with a couple of people
i let other people give their opinions
first and i talked with a few people uh
today about it we're all kind of in
unison about this i know there's
people who are the complete opposite
spectrum of our opinion on it for me my
main issue was actually brie larson's
performance in this movie i found her to
be a rather two-dimensional performance
she's very sarcastic she's sly she's
slick she's a rebel
but that's about it for me i felt like
that's
she's got the surface level down of it
but i didn't really feel a nuance in
there i didn't really feel this
depth in there and uh i'll let you guys
elaborate in a second like to get my
point across i was sort of watching it
going
this felt like it could have used a
little bit of that actually you know
what i feel like it could have used a
little bit of wonder woman meets jessica
jones you know how i'm born identity
he's a guy who has like all these
incredible
like powers essentially and all these
incredible skills and no one could beat
him no one could take him down
but but there's this whole longing for
like what's my identity where do my
powers come from what's my
past and you could feel that all
underneath and i felt like they could
have infused that
here but just with the captain marvel
humor with her performance on top of
that that's why i was kind of
referencing
a wonder woman-like character with a
jessica jones-like character because
jessica jones has that similar thing
where
she's very sarcastic on the surface very
snarky on the surface
but there's a lot of layers underneath
all that for me watching this movie
i couldn't tell if it was a directing
choice or purely an acting choice
because in general breed larson is one
of the greatest working actors and
actresses today she's without a doubt
one of the best so i was a little let
down by her because i think the
physicality of her character was good i
thought the action scenes of her
character were really good for me
through most of the movie
i really just felt a really surface
level performance with the same kind of
one note delivery for most of the jokes
the same kind of snarky smile throughout
i didn't feel much for a character i
didn't connect with her character
so by the time you get to the big
captain marvel moment i was like that's
cool visual effects it's some cool
action but i i don't
really care it's interesting you talked
about jessica jones because
then captain marvel you see a few scenes
of her as a younger girl
you see a couple of examples just
flashes of
why she acts the way she does but it's
just the movie
telling you how you should feel about it
and how you should
feel about her and view her it's not her
saying why she feels the way she feels
or
how she feels about certain situations
she's generally talk about
the emotional weight of things that have
been revealed or go on
as the movie progresses it just kind of
like tries to make you feel that way
versus earning
your emotions yes because there's a big
moment in the movie where later
like way late into the movie the moments
you're talking about are very
expositional this is how you're supposed
to feel this is what's going on
but yet i'm not seeing that underneath
her perform i'm not feeling that for her
and there's a moment where she's like i
don't even know who i
am and i felt like that big emotional
moment
wasn't really felt for me personally
because that felt like that should have
been a build up to that moment
throughout the movie
and said i'm like okay now we we finally
got this one
scene of her saying that but everything
leading up to that i didn't really
i just didn't feel for her in it but i
will clarify too is like
you know when i first saw uh chris uh
hemsworth this thor i thought he was
fine chris evans i thought he was fine
as captain america but as they evolved
in the mcu
i grew to really love them and i have a
feeling because it's
[ __ ] bree larsen so i have a feeling
that maybe an avengers end game
like what they whatever they do with her
under the hands of different directors
and a different point in her life i feel
like i'm i could probably latch on to
her
uh then you know but guys but yeah what
are your what are your overall feelings
about bree larson's performance in the
movie if i'd detract anything i would
just put that on the writing mostly
because i do think that a lot of times
i've heard that
sporting characters do a lot of the
emotional leg work for making you feel
for her and i think part of that is just
because the plot is so
kinetic and it's always moving there's a
lot to to do
for me with her performance it's like
i've given a million passes to films
with
guy characters who are exactly like that
who have less personality and
for this you know i came in and the big
question mark was what's her personality
going to be like because these promo
photos just aren't communicating it
and early on i was like i don't know i'm
enjoying her attitude and her energy
i wasn't necessarily like she's my
favorite marvel character ever but i
didn't really have any
issues and i thought at least some of
the visual motifs they used especially
flipping through those memories on rapid
and uh that all the memories are very
kind of of a specific
variety and so the visual element of
that
drove it home for me and i think the
critical element is i just wanted to
know
and thus i cared so like yeah there the
character i think the film could have
taken some
time to have her have some internal
struggle on the other side i'm like
she's only got six years worth of memory
and she's a soldier trained to manage
her emotions at all times
so i get kind of maybe why this isn't
the most emotionally
forward performance see i don't think it
needs to be the most emotionally for
performance i mean we briefly talked
about it uh have you seen the movie
equilibrium
i haven't no it's a christian bale movie
and in that movie they're living in a
world
where basically everyone is supposed to
be emotionless that's like the whole
point
where everyone's supposed to suppress
their emotions and our main character in
that movie even though he's emotionless
you could tell there's something
underneath the surface and that's
you know when you think of like their
funny characters in the mcu
like tony stark or jessica jones with
their really sarcastic sense of humor
you could always tell that there's some
kind of inner conflict underneath that
and that's essentially what was missing
for me in her performance like they keep
having all this talk about like what's
her identity or she has these rage
problems but it's not really
shown in most of the scenes she's just
kind of funny handling business
so the emotional obstacle there is an
arc essentially i just didn't really
feel for it it kind of has a little bit
of superman syndrome because she's
[ __ ] captain marvel
you know or i'm like there's no real
threat here for her physically
uh because she could just beat like
literally almost every physical obstacle
usually came down to just get a little
stronger just
punch her away out of it worst threat
yeah essentially yeah well
the arc is her realizing where her power
comes from and
you know the nature of all that i still
feel like one of those
self-actualization arcs
i still feel like for like even the
stowaway characters there should still
be that additional because that's a
human performance is
stoic is usually a surface and there's
something underneath it that's that's my
main graph but like i said
i feel like uh i don't want to make this
like the [ __ ] on brie larson fest
because that's not what it is for me
that's the thing i feel most strongly
about because i'm like
captain marvel's the league character
they keep saying she's gonna be the new
face of the mcu
i guess a lot of this does come down to
sort of expectation and
the one thing i know about the whole
controversy from like [ __ ] dumb
asses on twitter and stuff have been
like don't watch this watch elita battle
angel instead you know
and i feel like that's such a stupid
thing what i will say is
i i feel like elita i think this is a
much better movie than elita battle
angel
but have you seen that yet i have you
saw for valentine's day oh yeah i did
that's
what everyone should have done
i feel like a lot of what that movie did
not do well in this movie did great in
the thing that i thought would lead to
battle angel did better was essentially
a similar thing where
elita is a girl with all these powers
and she's got a sarcastic and fun
personality but there's a lot of inner
conflict
underneath all that and i want to know
my passion and i felt like that movie
did it really well and i could have used
just a little bit more
of that i feel like i've spent way too
much time on this point because then i
really
but she's the main character yeah she's
the main character so i i do that's my
main issue with it yeah
but that's really i think the only issue
that people are going to hark on because
if you look at the movie as a whole this
is a great film you have to compare to
other pieces of [ __ ] out there
i mean this is solid performances it's
well about
fun it looks fantastic so i
you know i would put it on par with like
you know first thor
or captain america the first avenger
good phase one movie
yeah this is like a solid step towards
getting her self self-actualization and
that character actually talked about and
really getting to know her and having
that emotional punch
later like could they have done that in
this film probably
they they didn't really bring it home
they're trying to do a lot of they're
trying
a lot in the series yeah there's a lot
that
you got the jude law plot line you got
the annette benning plot line you got
the earth plot line and
and honestly there's some one thing uh i
don't know when you guys felt hooked by
this movie
smoke show right right away that was it
yeah receded hairline at all i don't
care
two minutes in how was that yeah i was
in it pretty much from the get-go when
they started digging around in her mind
when the scrolls were digging around her
mind
that was when it clinched me probably
but i was sitting there going oh wow oh
here we go yeah i kind of feel like a
mesh of star trek meets star wars i got
a bunch of vibes are you just saying
that because the kroll had little pointy
ears
well no the ma this is the whole the
thing i wouldn't say i'd say let more
star trek in less star wars
actually for this movie there's star
trek in there i mean when they're
on the cree home world i was getting
like blade runner or even elita vi like
very cyber punk
kind of vibes yeah and there uh when
they're on earth and stuff it feels
legitimately
at least when they're not pumping a 90s
joke at you like a 90s you know cop that
was a main issue for me too i uh
i don't i like i'm i was born in 1990 so
i'm a 90s
child the internet was slow yeah there
were so many
jokes there are some times in this movie
where they
just really hammer home 90s nostalgia
90s nostalgia not like it was sometimes
it was a little bit much
i've heard some people complain there's
a there's a fight in the finale where
they play a 90s song in the movie and
i liked that you see i like that too and
i know a few people who
really don't like that because guardians
of the galaxy is all like 70s and 80s
music and that's harping on that
nostalgia so why not this well i see
okay
here and i talked to john about this the
thing with that of why i think in
guardians it works is because the music
is so essential to the character of
star-lord like he's always listening to
the music and everything like that
where in here captain marvel because of
her memory lost everything doesn't
really have
90s nostalgia like the character doesn't
so when they start playing it it feels a
little forced sometimes and less
within the realm of the character per se
and i love
whenever this movie decided to go full
on weird there's a lot of
weird [ __ ] in this movie weirder than
any other mcu film like that
brain that uh toying with the mind
sequence that you see in the trailer
that's teased where she's upside down
like blue shock on her head that whole
sequence i
[ __ ] loved it and there were later
scenes in the finale where i'm like
damn that's some crazy weird [ __ ] and i
love it
and i gotta give them one of the things
i appreciated most about this movie i i
thought it was really tight overall
especially with how competitive it is
well pace is well edited
even in the visual motifs with cutting
from one scene to the next with like
someone's kicking a door and then
they're kicking a door into the next
scene like it's
but uh one thing i appreciate the most
on the heels of that is that it
jumps between a lot of different tones
and styles and genres and whatever
pretty fluid fashion because you're
going from a whole different world to
earth in the 90s in the past to other
different worlds to like the
atmosphere just outside of earth and it
never feels weird or like a frankenstein
monster and i feel like that is a just
an attest to how well marvel has done
building up the boundaries of their
universe and expanding those over time
yeah and it did get me excited for the
future of that yeah and i'm excited
like i said like for me i didn't really
love chris evans as captain america or
chris hemsworth thor
i really started to latch onto them by
the time we got to the first avengers
movie though
and then that's her next movie is end
game so for me i'm like i have a feeling
there's probably going to be more like
now that she knows her identity and
knows these things
i imagine her character will have
drastically changed or evolved in the
course of
27 years but keep a lookout for a
spoiler review overall i did really
enjoy it i do have my gripes with the
brie larson portrayal and i feel like
i'm not sure where that issue is if it's
just for acting or if it's the writing
or directing some people really pinpoint
the writing on that overall yeah i'd
recommend i think it's a really fun time
we got a pretty positive recommendation
solid
sunslim in the marvel movie you know all
right
anywho guys have you seen captain marvel
yet a lot of people who are not part of
press for there so maybe you've seen it
already let us know what you think of it
below and what hopes you have for it hey
goose
uh you guys yeah that's funny you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell
and hey uh check out stacey howard on
instagram and twitter and make sure to
get your tickets for
uh where there's a link in the
description box you know what it is
see you guys